grab your Ashley two dolls these are not
dolls Jim and contain your excitement
because we have an all new season of
black mirror in this video we'll be
looking at season five episode three
Rachel Jack and Ashley - which is the
origin story for Hannah Montana not
really thank God so get ready as we'll
be taking a deep dive into the ending
and if you want to skip ahead just to
the Easter eggs I posted a time stamp in
the description below to better
understand the ending we have to rewind
to the beginning unlike traditional
black mare stories which tend to follow
one character this episode follows three
it's so important the name of the
episode is literally named after those
three characters now you might think
that rachel is the main character here
after all we start on her spend most of
the beginning with her and the narrative
is largely pushed forward by her
obsession with the Ashley doll but I'll
go over in a bit why I think that's not
the case
Rachel's starting at a new school and
doesn't have a lot of friends she's
lonely not just because of her lack of
friends but she's lost her mother too
she lacks confidence and when someone
asks her whether she's gonna sign up for
the talent show she says no but Rachel's
defining feature is her obsession with
pop star Ashley OH
a woman who seemingly has the perfect
superstar life and in Rachel's mind is
something she wants to become she
practices her dance moves listens to all
her songs and asks her dad who doesn't
even know it's her birthday coming up to
get her and Ashley to doll and part of
the reason rachel loves Ashley so much
is her positive message and outlook on
life her lyrics are upbeat and
empowering saying things like you're on
a roll and you're gonna get what you
deserve as Ashley says in her interview
that means having the confidence to be
who you want to be the irony here is
that Ashley herself isn't in control of
her destiny she's trapped in this fake
world pretending to be something she
isn't she lives in a glass house just
like one of Kevin's mice and is
controlled by her domineering manager /
aunt Catherine if that isn't clear
enough she composes her own music
writing see the animal in the cage
you've built while talking to the
janitor at Rachel's high school Kevin
explains the inhumanity of poisoned
mousetraps and
they kill these creatures slowly
Ashley's poison is her medication from
her aunt which slowly eats away at her
too she yearns to be free which is best
personified when she stares longingly at
the rock-and-roll venue like Rachel
Ashley has no friends
they are oddly both similar and
dissimilar at the same time but back to
the mice analogy it doesn't stop at
Ashley both Rachel and Jack feel trapped
- rachel is trapped in a new school
unable to make friends while Jack is
trapped in the past unable to get over
the death of her mother and unable to
muster the courage to play her guitar
for others as rachel says sure ever
since she died all you do is mope around
with that stupid guitar which you're
probably not good at cuz you're too
scared to play in front of anyone it's
here that I think Jack shifts is the
real protagonist of the story
you see Rachel wants to have friends and
to be able to muster the courage to
perform at her talent show she achieves
both of these about halfway through the
episode although not in the way we'd
expect she fails miserably at the talent
show and her only friend becomes a robot
not to mention that rachel is fairly
passive in this story things happen to
her instead of her making things happen
her character when compared with Jack
and Ashley changes the least by the end
of the episode but let's look at Jack's
arc Jack wants to get over the death of
her mother and to find her own place in
the world she even reads Jim dodges
stone Junction which is a coming-of-age
tale in which the protagonist tries to
find his place in the world but the
whole getting over the death of her
mother is personified through her
gaining the courage to play her guitar
at the end of the episode not only that
but the irony of her playing alongside
the woman she made fun of her sister for
adoring is not lost on us but jack is
more of a protagonist simply because she
propels the story forward with her
actions for example she hides the Ashley
doll steals her dad's van and smashes
dr. monk in the back of the head with a
tray Jack hides her grief in music rock
and roll's septum piercings and dark
clothes a contrast to Rachel who prefers
light upbeat pop with empowering
messages at the end of the episode her
journey has brought her on stage with
Ashley and she is finally playing moving
on with her life but it's Ashley's
character who goes through the most
visible arc she's a woman who quote
feels like she's wearing someone else's
skin trapped in
version of herself which isn't who she
is in fact the part of her that her aunt
likes the one that's great at doing
press junkets and interviews constitutes
only four percent of her brain which
leads us to the main part of the story
the rise of Ashley eternal when
Catherine learns she could no longer
control Ashley she takes matters into
her own hands and she has several
motivations for doing so one Ashley
hasn't written an album in a while and
the stuff she's been coming out with
lately is drivel as she says to her
colleagues she's Ashley oh not Leonard
Cohen - they need a way to recoup their
losses from the Ashley - dolls and the
perfect way for that is a new album
three Catherine feels like she's owed
this she took Ashley in when her parents
died and feels responsible for Ashley's
success in her mind she molded Ashley
into the success she is today
so when Ashley tells her aunt that she's
breaking her contract she takes drastic
measures and poisons her own niece to
put her in a medically induced coma this
way they can access the creative part of
her brain and using some new software
continue to compose her music remember
that Ashley gets her song ideas from her
dreams so if they can access that
they're in business but there's just one
problem they can compose but they no
longer have Ashley's physical form
introducing Ashley eternal a
breakthrough hologram technology which
would allow for simultaneous concerts
around the globe and did I mention
scalability it's only when the doll
overhears a news broadcast involving
Ashley's coma
does it go haywire and malfunction the
girls take it to their fathers lab
hoping to fix it but instead unlock its
entire memory apparently every Ashley to
doll was instilled with the entirety of
Ashley's personality but were given
what's called a limiter the limiter
would only allow the perky fun Ashley
image that fans know while suppressing
everything else but now that it's been
removed the Ashley - doll tells them the
truth that there was no way her coma was
caused by an allergic reaction to
shellfish so the girls do the only
logical thing and steal their dads truck
to break into Ashley's house and find
proof that her aunt is responsible
apparently Ashley's laptop has a backup
of her diary and will contain this proof
but as we'll find out later this isn't
the case Ashley - isn't here to get
proof of anything she's here to put an
end to her own suffering and ends
pulling the life-support plug in our own
body now this is interesting because
it's almost as if you were to pull the
plug on yourself it's Ashley's own
consciousness in that doll as she tells
Rachel about her decision
Rachel listen I know me okay and I know
I wouldn't exist even ten minutes in
that state but things aren't always what
they seem in black mirror Ashley wakes
up seemingly from the dead and scares
the crap out of Rachel and Jack she
wasn't on life support she was being
medically sedated in order for Catherine
to exploit her they escape from dr. monk
and speed off to confront Catherine at
her investors meeting where she's
unveiling Ashley eternal here we can see
some of the features which include
extended and enhanced physical life the
ability to perform in harsh environments
like the moon and the ability to control
its consciousness gone will be the days
of performers getting sick an AI infused
with the artist can manifest itself in
hologram form and perform anywhere
around the globe and beyond all that's
needed is a dude and a motion capture
suit and you're good to go
oh and costume changes are real easy and
the girls come in like a wrecking ball
totally crashing the investor meeting
here Catherine knows the gig is up we
also get this little post credit
sequence showing Ashley embracing her
true self performing alongside Jack at
the club she longingly stared at at the
beginning of the episode she's no longer
trapped floating freely above the crowd
we also get Kevin trying to sell his
shitty rat contraption and the two girls
who were seen crying over Ashley's
allergic reaction who aren't too
thrilled about Ashley's new look and
that's the point this story is about
being yourself not what others want you
to be now for a little bit of fun let's
go over this episode's Easter eggs over
a telecast the report exclaims that
Ashley was rushed to st. junipers
Hospital a nod to season three's Sam
Junipero which is also shown in
Bandersnatch as st. junipers medical
practice san Junipero also deals with
the idea of having consciousness
transferred through technology and st.
junipers is also where Peter Dawson
worked in season fours black Museum
episode on the newscast we get several
fun bits of Easter eggs in the ticker
below like narrative creator still
missing which is likely a nod to game
design or Colin Rickman who goes missing
and Bandersnatch although the timelines
don't quite
match up with that since that was said
in the 80s so it could be his daughter
who took over his legacy and guess what
the name of Rachel's High School is
written in hi the song Ashley Oh sings
on a roll is a rewrite of The Nine Inch
Nails song head like a hole which Trent
Reznor gave his blessing for black Mayer
to do Gervin Records is named after
story editor David Gervin and the
director and Savitsky is the actual
director of the entire episode
continuing with Nine Inch Nails the song
Ashley sings on her own here is the song
right where it belongs now I'd love to
play a clip of that but that's just a
trip to demonetised City during the
newscast we find out the network is USN
which is likely the American spin-off of
the British version we've seen in Black
Mirror ukm and on the tikar below we get
more Easter eggs like architec arrested
on multiple murder charges a reference
to Mia Nolan's character in season fours
crocodile there's also cited gembo
Cher's jump on striking vipers release
which is a reference to episode 2 which
I haven't seen yet guys but I know
striking vipers is the name of that
episode and then there's museum owners
body found in smoking ruins which of
course is a reference to Rolo Haynes who
died when his museum was burned in
season 4 can't forget tusk the rapper
from season 3's hated in the nation who
was a target of the hashtag death to
campaign and get your cosplay ready
because we have Sea of Tranquility which
was the name of the movie the cosplayers
were going to on the bus lacy Hopson in
season three's nosedive that's it for
this black mirror ending explained in
Easter eggs if you like these videos
please give it a thumbs up comment and
subscribe I'm going to be doing a video
for each episode this season so stay
tuned and if you like you can follow me
on twitter at think story whitey until
next time remember daddy loves you very
much